- So wait, I heard, I get
it that you had a fun way
to keep your cast entertained.
What is that?
- Well, I would ask trivia
questions, you know?
- [Kelly] Oh.
- Yeah, I get people-
- Are you a game person?
- Would sort of, yeah, I could
try one on you if you like.
- Okay. Go ahead. Oh gosh.
- Well it's-
- Not like hardcore "Trivial Pursuit."
Know your audience.
- [Kenneth] No, no, no.
(Annette and audience laugh)
Absolutely.
But I could say,
maybe some of the distinguished colleagues
in the audience might know this,
back in the, you know, the early days,
September, 2002, when you
had your amazing triumph-
- [Kelly] Oh. Okay.
- on "Pop Idol."
- [Kelly] I know what happened, yup.
- [Kenneth] I know what
I want you to tell me.
- I love that you noticed "Pop Idol."
- I want you to tell me,
you won with what percentage
of the votes from viewers?
- [Annette] Oh, stop.
- [Kelly] They don't tell you.
They don't tell you.
- [Kenneth] Well.
- [Kelly] Do you know?
- The figure is out there. I can tell you.
- [Kelly] You know?
- And maybe some of our,
I know what percentage of-
- I don't know.
- You don't know?
- I'm gonna say, like, 54.
- Oh.
- [Kelly] Well, because at- oh 58!
- [Kenneth] 58%!
- It was pretty close!
I was gonna say, I knew
it had to be around,
'cause I knew I didn't win by a ton
'cause everybody loved Justin as well,
and now he's,
♪ It's a sweet thing ♪
I love him.
He looks so good in those commercials.